[Music]
welcome back to our energized developer
Community here in Munich and to those of
you watching online I hope you grabbed a
coffee and stretched your legs so for
our first tech track today we're going
to hear some reasons why your Java app
should find its home on Google cloud and
I'd like to welcome application
development customer engineer for
startups and scale-ups Dario Banfi
[Music]
Google Cloud next here in Munich uh it's
so great to see so many of you
interested in Java especially since
there is also a goaling track going on
in the other room but it's good to see
so many Java developers
um
today I'm going to talk about five
reasons why your Java apps are better on
Google Cloud
and I know it's quite a bold statement
here I have 20 minutes to explain myself
so yeah I I'll get to it soon
my name is Dario Banfield I'm a customer
engineer here in Munich I actually live
100 meters from this venue and this is
not why I got invited to talk here but
the reason why I'm here it's because I'm
a Java developer myself
I've done Java on multiple layers of the
stack I've built a graphical user
applications with Java Swing
I recommend it I've used a lot of spring
I've done Android development kotlin
development so I've seen Java in a lot
of different forms and one thing I want
to talk about is how I think that Google
cloud is a great way to ask your job
application so let me let me get to it
let me get to the reason so reason
number one it's about being able to
deploy in seconds
so whenever you write an application you
don't want to spend a lot of time uh you
know dealing with servers jvm setting
your Java home you you want to just be
able to write your code and have it
running on Google Cloud very quickly
and with this you can do it very easily
with cloudrun on Google Cloud so Cloud
run is our fully managed container based
serverless platform
it lets you build your code package it
as a container and deploy it on top of
our scalable infrastructure and it gives
you a lot of features out of the box
like Auto scaling scaling to zero
observability and so on
so it's a great fit for Java and also
other languages of course but it's a
it's a great way for you to really save
on you know the deployment time that you
would otherwise be spending and the good
thing about Cloud run there was the quiz
question earlier it supports any
language you just need to package your
application as a container
and if you're using Java you don't even
need to write a container a Docker file
actually we support building from source
using uh under the HUD Cloud native
buildbacks with Builder packs you can
our software automatically detect the
language of your application and we'll
create a container for it so that you
don't even need to do that
let's let's see an example right so I
will walk you through a fictitious Java
application that we will create because
I don't have a demo but it's quite
simple so we can follow it like this
first of all we will curl from the
spring website the starter kit choosing
dependency web so this is just like a
simple Java API service that we want to
deploy
we don't load it on our local machine
and after that we unzip it and then we
will open the demo application Java so
the main class where our application
code will run
once we do that we just want to add a
sign of life right like a message from
saying hello from cloud run so in Spring
we just put an annotation a rest
controller we put a get mapping with a
root URL and then we are good to go
our simple application is ready we can
deploy it we can test it out
and when it comes to the deployment
phase I I'm a lazy developer and I
always ask myself what is the least
infrastructure management that meets my
needs
and I already said Cloud run is actually
a very good use case for this so we can
use cloud runs we go in the directory of
our code and all we need to do is run
the command gcloud run deploy
this command will interactively ask us
which apis we want to enable for example
artifact registry right like we want
this container stored in a container
registry and then it will ask us which
region we want to deploy it into
as of now we have 35 regions and just at
this conference we are announcing so
many more six or five so
um you have like quite a lot of choice
in order to get your applications very
close to your users
if you do need more customization you
can also put a cloud builder.tml file in
your directory this will gives you the
configuration needed to for cloud build
our CI CD manage the platform and
for example is never a bad idea writing
some tests before deploying the code so
you can do this with Cloud build you can
add multiple steps and in Cloud build
each steps will be run by a separate
container so that you can choose very
specifically which dependency you want
to have in your container in order to
deploy your application so when you
deploy for example we can use the
container Cloud SDK which is provided by
us and lets you have like a gcloud
command line configured and ready to go
all right so this was a reason number
one ease of deployment
now let's let me get to reason number
two
after you deploy your application it's a
good practice to not have the entirety
of your traffic going to the new version
right away in case you have some issue I
don't know testing doesn't always catch
the issue so this practice is called the
canary deployments Canary rollouts and
it normally takes quite some effort to
build it yourself right like you need to
implement this logic and have this as
part of your cicd which is quite some
work and I don't want to do that
so we can use a cloud run a traffic
splitting feature for that
and for those of you who have seen it
you can go in the console you will have
your button managed traffic and from
there you will be able to select how
much traffic you want to each revision
a good practice is for example deploying
the fourth container with no traffic and
then scale it up and you can do this in
multiple multiple ways you can do it in
the console you can do it with a command
line you can do it uh probably like the
best will be to script is as part of
your CI CD so that's it's an automated
process ideally like with also some
automated monitoring in case your
production issues as some bugs so the
possibility are endless but the cool
thing is that it's really part of cloud
run and it's very simple to use
all right let me get to reason number
three so and this is really Java focused
right so
a couple of months ago we announced that
we have some optimization with Java
client libraries
so if you use for example uh bigquery or
if you use Pub sub or if you use any
Cloud native Google cloud service in
your application you probably have a
library for that
and our libraries now support natively
code compilation
for uh for uh for a native executable in
Java so that's a quite a good thing that
takes you that so you don't have to do
it yourself right you don't have to play
around with the configuration which is
also quite some work
I'll explain a bit more about that but
let me zoom out a bit let's talk about
Cloud run right uh
Cloud run as I said gives you Auto
scaling out of the box so you have here
three containers right your application
is getting a lot of traffic so Cloud run
started multiple instances of the
service
what happens that if the traffic goes
down Cloud run will also scale down
until you get to zero no more containers
and this is normally quite good for you
because you're actually not paying for
this container right so scaling to zero
is actually a very useful feature
depending on the application you have
the problem is that whenever you will
get the first request you will have
what's called in cloud computing as a
cold start so cold start me are is the
delay that it takes from cloud run to
start your container from a state where
there is no containers
and your users can experience that and
of course it can be annoying or
depending on your application it can
become a problem
so how do we solve that there is
a couple of ways the simplest one is to
use in Cloud run the concept of minimum
instances
with minimum instances you say that I
want this amount of container to be
running always at the same time so that
you completely avoid the problem of cold
start the container will be always
running but you also lose the advantage
that we discussed that you are going to
be paying for this container actually
the price is a bit lower so if you check
on the pricing page you can learn about
it but still you're paying the right and
we don't want that
and the second way to do it is Java
native compilation
this became a really popular a couple of
years ago with ground VM I'm sure many
of you already play with that and the
difference is quite significant for
cloud native application especially for
containerized workloads that run
kubernetes or a serverless platform and
let's see an example right I I made with
the same service I downloaded earlier I
made an example between a native
application which will have a startup
startup time of around 486 millisecond
and your traditional Java application
where the startup time will be around
seven seconds so this is almost like one
order of magnitude more and yeah it's
it's quite relevant
native compilation has other benefits
also there is not only startup time it's
also about memory utilization Peak
Performance
and it also has just some drawbacks but
depending on your use case it can be a
great uh tool to use and let me quickly
explain the difference
um between just in time compilation
which we use in your traditional Java
application so you write your Java code
it gets compiled to bytecode and then
this bytecode is translated to machine
code Just In Time by the Java virtual
machine
when you use ahead of time compilation
this is done ahead of time this is done
before so the this the machine code will
be generated and will be run directly on
the architecture where you are deploying
to
um and uh yeah as I said for cloud
native workloads it can be really
Adventures advantages
so going back to the initial
announcement uh we all of our libraries
supported Java native complete
compilation and yeah I invite you to try
this out and in your application and I
I'm also going to give you a couple of
concrete tips on how to do that
um if you're using for you're using for
example spring native which is probably
like the most popular Java framework I
would say you can further improve the
performance by optimizing the classes
that get loaded in the class path as
startup time so for example we have a
spring accept expression language we
have XML if you don't need them you can
use this configuration to remove them
you can also use a spring native class
initialization so for example you can
say which classes should be initialized
at build time versus runtime and I could
take talk for hours here because Java
typically initializes classes at runtime
and this is as like a of course like a
latency
tall on your application
so with this Flex you can reduce that
it's not super simple right like you
need to read a bit which classes can be
initialized at real time because it's
not valid for all type of classes they
need to be safe classes but it's also
like another performance Improvement
that you can Leverage
and then lastly it's a native quick
build mode so if you ever built a Java
native application and you don't have a
powerful computer you know the pain it
will start flying out of your room
so with Native quick build mode you can
actually reduce the time it takes to
compile your Java application you just
pass the minus zero B flag
and the the the timer will be quite
significant so this is the time it takes
for a normal compilation right so 63
seconds four gigabyte of memory and we
take quick build mode it's going to be
42 seconds and less than half the memory
so it's pretty good especially if you
build hundreds of containers per day
all right let me go to number four it's
about security we talked already a lot
about that about uh you know salsa which
is not the Mexican Dipa but it stands
for supply chain levels for software
artifacts
it's a security framework that gives you
some prescriptive measures on how to
secure your cicd pipeline and this
became quite relevant after the
solarwinds heck a couple of years ago
where the cicd was compromised and some
malicious code was deployed to multiple
environments
so if you want to enable sign builds you
can use binary authorization this makes
sure that only code that gets built by
your CI CD pipeline is allowed to be
deployed in cloudron
let's see how it looks so if you go on
cloud run you can go to your services
and you can go on the details page in
the console for example
from there you will see that there is a
binary authorization flag so you can
enable it
and once you enable it you have to
configure a policy which which you can
do by clicking the button or scripting
it
once you do that you will see that there
is a summer testers
testers are entities which are allowed
to sign a given build and this build
will be cryptographically signed right
so in our policy we will click edit and
we will say that
only a specific a tester like built by
Cloud build in this case is Maya tester
will be allowed to deploy on cloud run
so you just click the checkbox required
attestation and from now on no other
image which is not built by Cloud build
will be allowed to be deployed so it's
pretty neat so you you know for sure
that no one can just deploy an image
from the docker registry without
approval and you can make sure that your
CI CD becomes the central place where
security is enforced for example you
create some Security checks you create
some building ability scanning we talked
about today about open source Library
scanning so this is a great place to do
it and it's a great way to enforce it
all right so this was my reason number
four so now comes to the last reason
which is actually an announcement we are
making at next
and the announcement is that Google
Cloud joined the eclipse adoption
working group
eclipse adoptum is a consortiums of java
leaders which is uh the entity behind
the temori build of java
has been become really popular in the
past years it's one of the mostly most
used jdk and it has like the highest
standards of uh security of
compatibility so from now on uh or like
not now on but very soon you will be
able to use the Tamarin build in all of
our serverless products so including for
example Cloud functions app engine so it
will be the jdk behind the your Java
application so we are looking forward
for you to try this out
and yeah so let me recap I covered a lot
of ground so five reasons easy
deployments and Payless with Cloud run
salsa compliant uh out of the box a lot
of features
one of these is of course Advanced
deployment patterns using a traffic
splitting using this concept of canary
rollouts
you get native image support for your
Java client libraries so
go on and try building your Java
applications to native code
and you get security from the CI CD
using signed bills to production using
very soon the tamarina jdk into your
application
all right so that was it I hope I could
teach you something new and I hope you
enjoy the rest of the session today
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]